for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
so in the previous video I showed how
phenylalanine and tyrosine were both
broken down to acetyl co a and how they
ended up also giving off humor rights so
these are the two amino acids that are
degraded to fumarate and I figured I'd
go through some of the details here and
eventually related to relate the details
of the oxidation of these amino acids to
PKU phenylketonuria so phenylalanine of
course undergoes the phenylalanine
hydroxylase reaction to give tyrosine
alright adding that o h there and then
that tyrosine is turned into para
hydroxy phenyl pyruvate which is just
the alpha keto acid version of this we
remove this amino group and attached it
to alpha cute little rate to give
glutamate and that is done by an amino
transferase specifically tyrosine amino
transferase that requires part off so
phosphate as a cofactor then that para
hydroxy phenyl pyruvate is turn into
homo gentes 8 by para hydroxy phenyl
pyruvate dioxygenase and this carboxyl
group comes off as a carbon dioxide so
we go from a 9 carbon molecule to an 8
carbon molecule and specifically this
ch2 group along with this carbonyl come
off and they sort of get attached to you
they get moved over here and we also
oxidize this carbon to make it a
carboxyl group and that's what the
oxygen there is for so and we also get
this hydroxyl group at it so it's a
dioxygen ace okay then this homo gentes
8 this 8 carbon molecule gives rise to
maleo acetyl acetate with this homo
gentes a 1/2 dioxygen ace
and so they're basically the ring is
broken up and gives us this molecule
here to the right malleolus Utah State
where these four carbons are basically
going to be the acetoacetate portion and
then this portion will eventually come
off as a fumarate in fact we'll see that
that is actually converted into humeral
acetoacetate which basically turns this
double bond here from a syst double bond
from a system a bond to a trans double
bond so that this small this portion of
the molecule with the blue carbons can
actually come off as a fumarate so that
this is the malleable acetal malleolus
Ito acetate isomerase reaction turning
it from the sis isomer to the trans
isomer and then this this fumarole
acetyl acetate here is cleaved such that
this portion comes off as a fumarate so
the carbons from those amino acids end
up in fumarate and of course that can go
to the TCA cycle get oxidized and then
this portion up here we saw already ends
up as acetyl acetate and this is
catalyzed by fumarole acetyl acetate and
that acetate acetoacetate gives us you
know I see the walkaway and then the two
acetyl COAS as we saw in the previous
video okay so why am i bringing this up
a lot of amino acids are of importance
when it comes to nervous system
physiology okay
for example glutamate is actually a
neurotransmitter tryptophan gives is a
precursor to serotonin which is also at
neurotransmitter and tyrosine is a
precursor for dopamine which is a
neurotransmitter epinephrine which is a
hormone and norepinephrine which is a
neurotransmitter and kind of like a
hormone so that's called a neurohormone
notice that with tyrosine intarsia
giving rise to these three
should make sense because of that
aromatic group the aromatic group with
the hydroxyl group there that's coming
from tyrosine these these molecules all
come from tyrosine so what so what's the
point of me mentioning this well the
answer is simply that problems with
amino acid metabolism can lead to issues
with the nervous system an example of
which the reason I'm talking about this
video is phenol ketonuria or PKU
that is a specific situation in which
you have impaired metabolism of
phenylalanine that is classically caused
by a genetic deficiency of phenyl
alanine hydroxylase which is the enzyme
that converts phenylalanine to tyrosine
which is what we saw up at the top here
and also in the previous video though we
didn't talk about it much in the
previous video right here this enzyme
phenylalanine hydroxylase is deficient
in PKU okay I forgot to show here that
cofactor tetrahydrobiopterin which is
also actually important here the point
is that this this enzyme is deficient in
PKU
so what's the deal with that what
happens well if this reaction can't
happen if the enzyme that catalyzes this
forward reaction is is deficient that
means that this reaction is not going to
happen okay or not going to happen
enough and so what ends up happening is
that the phenylalanine will build up
because it's not being converted into
tyrosine so we have an increased
concentration of phenylalanine which is
called hyper phenylalanine emia okay and
then we have a decreased concentration
of tyrosine because we're not making it
from phenylalanine and that's a problem
because the tyrosine is needed for the
that we mentioned before so there are
signs and symptoms of phenylketonuria
PKU and they are they include impaired
neuro development mental retardation
seizures and even actually hypo
pigmentation due to a lack of melanin
because melanin the pigment that darkens
skin comes from tyrosine as well so all
these are signs and symptoms of
basically having a lack of tyrosine and
so there's also you can also have
different other types of deficiencies
for instance if tyrosine amino
transferase is deficient that's that's
deficient and he's called tyrosinemia
too you can also have tyrosinemia 3
where this enzyme is deficient
you also have alkaptonuria when this
enzyme is deficient and if this enzyme
fumarole acetoacetate is deficient you'd
have tyrosinemia one anyway kind of
getting off track a little bit all over
the place here but with with the PKU
if if if a patient has PKU the treatment
is often a diet that is low in
phenylalanine so that the phenylalanine
concentrations don't get too high and
it's also often supplemented with
tyrosine so that you get enough tyrosine
and the great part about this is that
patients can at least depart from their
diet live pretty much normal lives which
is awesome by the way this is approached
100% from an academic perspective if you
have any concerns and would like medical
advice
none of nothing in this video should be
taken as medical advice definitely go
see your doctor ok so that's kind of the
situation with PKU now you you'll notice
that I put classically here with a
little asterisk about the the PKU being
classically caused by a genetic
deficiency of that enzyme it can also be
caused by a deficiency in
tetrahydrobiopterin or pH 4 which is the
cofactor in that reaction that turns
tyrosine so typically a classical PKU is
the deficiency in the enzyme but PKU can
also be caused by not having out for
that cofactor for that reaction because
either way the reaction can't happen
okay anyway I hope that video was
helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying